What do you think about this David?
>> So starting with Roomba,
I would put Roomba in the bottom left.
It definitely acts in the world.
But it definitely doesn't act like I do.
It crisscrosses across the floor
until it vacuums everything up.
So we're going to say
that's acting optimally.
C-3PO is fluent in over 6
million forms of communication.
And that means that it interacts with
human and other species very often.
In order to do that, it has to
understand natural sentences and
put its own knowledge back
into natural sentences.
So, it has to act like humans.
Apple's virtual assistant,
Siri, doesn't act in the world.
So she is more on the thinking
end of the spectrum but,
like C-3PO,
she has to interact with humans.
She has to read human sentences and
she has to put her own responses
back into normal vernacular.
So we're going to say that
she thinks like humans.
Google Maps plots your route from
your origin to your destination.
So it's definitely doing thinking,
it's not doing any acting in the world.
But we don't really care if it does
the route planning like we would do it.
So we would say it does its
route planning optimally.
It takes into consideration traffic.
Current construction,
different things like that,
where we would probably think of
the routes we have taken in the past.
So Google Maps thinks optimally.
>> That is a good answer David,
I agree with you, but not here that
some aspects of Siri, may well belong
in some of the other quadrants.
So, putting under 3 sounds plausible.
But Siri might also be viewed as,
perhaps, acting when it
gives you a response.
Siri, some aspects of Siri might also be
optimal, not necessarily like humans.
>> So if you'd like to discuss where
these technologies belong on these
spectrums or, perhaps, discuss where
some other AI technologies that you're
familiar with belong on these spectrums,
feel free to head on over to our forums
where you can bring up your own
technologies and discuss the different.
Ways in which they fit into
the broader school of AI.